you like that stuff Kobe Bryant always
had his little ladies by his side his
biggest days for the NBA legend there
was nothing like being a girl dad as
their daughter Bianca was about a year
and a half old at the time so I asked if
he wanted more children and he said that
his wife Vanessa really wanted to try
again for a boy but was sort of jokingly
concerned that it would be another girl
and I was like four girls are you joking
like what would you think how would you
feel and without hesitation he said I
would have five more girls if I could
I'm a girl dad he first became a father
in 2003 when Natalia was born she really
daddy's girl Oh 100% oh yeah completely
like she's totally bummed out when I
have to go somewhere take it to the
movies all the time
Italian daughters Gianna Bianca and
three all followed Gianna was the black
mambas mamacita following in her dad's
basketball footsteps and fans that come
up to me and she'll be standing next to
me and be like and you gotta have a boy
you and Vee gotta have a boy yeah
somebody carry on your tradition the
legacy she's like oh yeah I got this
[Applause]
their bond was like nothing else they
were best of friends weren't the two
peas in a pod Natalya would be at
volleyball with mom Vanessa would be at
volleyball and then coke and Gigi would
be at the tournaments you know so he
spoke proudly about all this girls
including the baby girls but you know it
was a special twinkle in his eye when
you're talking Gigi and basketball coach
Gianna shared the middle spot in the
family with now three-year-old Bianca
the Bryant family's little ball of
energy she has so much energy
it's outrageous like it's
oh I mean it's crazy like she'll do
gymnastics like Mommy and Me class and
then swim class and then she'll come
home and run around and then she'll want
to you know shoot hoops with Gigi in the
chute and then you come like you know 8
o'clock 9 o'clock
kids ready to go to sleep right no she's
still going still going still going the
kid does not stop like we call it a
little mini tornado
Capri at 8 months old is the youngest of
Kobe's four girls are you gonna go at 5
or you gonna go for 500
well that's v's call oh is it that's B's
cause it's completely B's call but I
mean we're just really blessed very
fortunate Kobe took pride in having all
girls and during his last interview with
et he opened up about how they inspired
one of his final projects the wizards
series of books you love this book
because it's a way to communicate with
your girls who are getting a little
older and they don't want to always hear
from dad yeah just true with all of our
stories coming out so all the messaging
is things that as a parent we want our
kids to learn no yeah it's like you have
kids all you know it becomes white noise
after a while they're like all right
what do you guys know you guys don't
know what you're talking about
so finding creative ways to put those
very impactful messages within the story
this way we do it in a creative way
[Music]
you